all right border patrol apprehending
three illegal immigrants who broke into
a home in sierra blanco texas
this happened this week they stole two
loaded handguns ammunition food and
clothing
governor greg abbott setting aside by
the way 250 million dollars
to begin the state-funded border wall so
as the migrant crisis continues to
impact americans and the bite
administration ignores it
how is it living under the border
conditions on the southern border how do
land owners handle it
my next guest has had multiple
encounters with migrants on our property
texas landowner mother of three uh
allison anderson joins us now allison
can you give us an idea what it's like
being you
um no one's ever asked me that before um
currently it's it's challenging
because i am constantly concerned right
now with
my family's safety and that especially
of our three
daughters so when people say well that's
because you live on the border
has it always been like this have you
always been concerned about your
your family's safety i think our
situation is unique because we used to
live on a very large ranch west of del
rio
but we moved to del rio seeking you know
the nice quiet
safe yard that our girls could grow up
and play in and
within the last six months or so
activities here
it was peaceful for a while i was
actually enjoying having peace of mind
and allowing our kids to play outside
but
um they can't do that anymore so
activities have increased and even in
the last couple weeks
they've increased dramatically i have
neighbors constantly calling me
elderly neighbors specifically that are
concerned and fearful so
we're kind of on call and um you know
we're here to help
our neighbors as well who are afraid so
i'm just going to give
everybody out there a sense of the
numbers and what's changing
on the border in january there are 11
000 apprehensions in may it's almost
30 000. it's supposed to be even much
higher
in june they said it was going to level
off because it gets so hot
have you seen a leveling off absolutely
not
absolutely not it all we've seen here is
an increase and
what i can say in all the years that
i've had personal experience
in dealing with illegal aliens um we
have never dealt with a single family
unit
not a single family unit and the
individuals that are coming through here
i mean there was just a convicted rapist
that was caught not too far from our
property
in route on a trail that was basically
leading him
to our property so absolutely not
actually three nights ago there was a
group at our next door neighbor's house
circling the vehicles and tapping on
their daughter's bedroom window
you said no family units so who are the
people coming across
i mean i can only assume but they're
they're all males there's no females out
on on i mean we live west
of del rio and there's no females out
here there's no children out here and
there are absolutely no family units out
in this way
it's all mostly single males that are
traveling in groups so allison the
people i
we measure are the ones we apprehend or
turn themselves in they get processed
and now they're getting a catch and
release the people you're talking about
aren't getting processed
they're not even being counted yeah
exactly
yeah and if you consider even
what those numbers might be i mean it's
it's unacceptable
there should no one here should be
afraid of you know having their kids
play in their yard or riding their bikes
down the street and none of my neighbors
should be fearful of going out to water
their plants in the morning or the
evening and
being able to sleep at night and what do
you tell local law enforcement
i mean i always thank them because i
mean we personally had a
bailout on our property and because
border patrol couldn't respond because
they were busy processing family units
that day dps responded
so it's just i mean i'm grateful for the
additional support that we're getting
here with
law enforcement i just you know i wish
border patrol was able to go
and do their jobs again and work groups
actively out in the brush and in the
field
what is your message for washington
about
what the reality is living on the border
in texas
it's it's scary i want safety i want
something done
we've been i mean my family personally
has been dealing with illegal immigrants
for years
and nothing's been done and we left a
place
specifically moved to a place peace of
mind and
i mean it's worse here now than where it
was and why we left it's it's worse here
i bet
by the end of this year my encounters
personally will probably surpass
all of those that i dealt with on the
ranch and you got to think that
uh there's some of these people uh have
evil intentions
and unfortunately you're deal you have
to deal with it alone allison anderson
mom of three uh living in texas on the
border that's what your life is like and
it is not right
thanks so much for sharing your story
thank you so much
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary
any great news bites any great
interviews coming your way on fox you
can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now